minister leonel carmen says pop-up
clinics last summer helped the province
cut the number of people who were
unvaccinated in half currently 92
percent of quebec adults have received
at least one shot of the vaccine but
that still leaves over 500 thousand
quebecers who have not yet received
their first dose camas says the
unvaccinated are really three separate
groups anti-vaccine the vaccine hesitant
and marginalized populations he says the
government is partnering with community
organizations in order to target the
last two groups there's a new phone line
for people who want to discuss the risks
and benefits of vaccination with a
professional and there will be more
pop-up clinics that take walk-ins
beginning with one this thursday at the
clsc san catherine in downtown montreal
but the minister was also asked why the
government wasn't going even further
like knocking on doors or even
attempting to call people directly who
haven't been vaccinated he said that is
not his approach all these little things
that we want to do
will give us as many people as possible
that we can reach i mean i'm sure
i'm not thinking i'm going to reach 100
of the population but i want to reach as
many as possible to make this as
effective as possible the question now
though is if not one hundred percent how
many people can the government reach
camach said he would not set a specific
target for himself
raquel fletcher global news quebec city